that's
it now me and you are
[Music]
play B
I'm
I'm I'm pring
[Music]
I'm going
to he's going to block then I take same
technique
[Music]
so if he doesn't
block stri right
here n on the
strike help startle him even more you
kind of yell at him
[Music]
harder no no no the person stri
that's
thech the block
[Music]
he this way you understand
if you strike straight like this often
times you're on the other side of your
hand you strike across put your hand
down I go to one side of my body Bo and
I'm hitting the temple on the other side
of his
head okay that's the idea so don't come
straight
across any
blocks so not
straight across
boom with intention
[Music]
okay it's all about authenticity making
things
real you can't just go in your head and
feel well I tired of playing games I
don't want to be in the baby class
anymore or and you can't just be what
this is called an
overachiever oh for the parents I want
my kid to be in the advanced class
that's not
real real is to have this deep deep
sincerity behind what you're doing and
saying and thinking okay so you need to
have a real relationship with your
teacher a real relationship with the Mad
a real relationship with the technique
you're
practicing it's not enough just to be
here that's why training here is
difficult sometimes makes us sad makes
us happy sometimes makes us mad
sometimes because you're training at
deeper
levels okay so if you feel feel sad
don't worry that means you're training
deeply that's a good thing if you feel a
little angry at sometimes or a little
frustrated that's okay too that means
you're training for real people who
don't care don't feel
anything that's called apathy when we we
a word means no feeling you don't feel
anything that means you're not alive
your art is not alive you have to train
with real real feeling real passion real
Integrity real
sincerity can't just show
up so as I'm your teacher I look for the
day when you really are upset about your
art when you really are upset about iido
cuz that tells me oh finally they're
really training they really have their
heart in the training they really have
their mind in the training